hey everyone I'm a beach art welcome to
Abby's kitchen I'm here with my friend
not be silly from Fidel Castro's so
Brown they're a little bit competitive
and we recently have had to tithe in our
food competitions before but you may
remember our beer competition which I
used ribs for and I did salad and then
we did of course a candidate burgers
thing mine was a triple decker with
Canadian bacon maple syrup well I also
have to mean bacon if I was a torch a
burger and it was so good so we're back
at his date with a little meatball
kurodo math Italian and I didn't want to
mess with that situation yes the entire
sauna situation no it's a way of life
it's a way of life capiche capiche
so if I put a little twist on things
with my magical beans Oh mine are
magical they're just too proper well say
that is just saying it's got meat there
so I'm gonna give you a sneak peek of
Matt's recipe right here but of course
you get the full recipe you've got to
check out his channel
bring on the balls okay Matt so we're
gonna start with some rolled oats and
this is gonna emulate the breadcrumb
factor but a little higher in fiber and
better for us
so now I always preheat my pan at 350
degrees before we put our meatballs on
because the residual heat in the pan
actually starts to cook the bottom of
the meatballs you get some browning on
there that make sense just on top so
we're gonna roll these in about 2 tbsp
did you go for it man
okay so we've baked off our bean balls
they're all ready to go I just have to
get them a little bit of extra love in a
nonstick skillet with just a touch of
vegetable or olive oil
then I add my zucchini noodles to a nice
pot along with a little bit of your
favorite pasta sauce
I'm gonna go yeah all right well I mean
I think you need to meet to win the
meatball competition I'm just gonna
throw that out there that's just a
technicality okay I gotta say for a
meatless meatball you did good you did
good kid well for a meat meatball and it
is so I think we're not agree it's on
this not again not again not again the
bookies didn't see that one Wow guides
for more great recipes including Matt's
amazing meatball recipes not gonna lie
they're pretty good you've got to check
out his channel here and of course for
more great healthy recipes be sure to
subscribe to my channel and I'll see you
next time on Abbey's kitchen let's tie
ball balsa coral balls